welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the rick
and morty season five two-part finale
for getting saric mortal and rick mirai
jack together a heartbreaking game
changer to the series with insane
implications of the future but also as
always i know what you nerd junkies want
tons of subtle animation details that
are awesome to discover and i'm going to
break them down frame by frame we open
on morty rescuing a dessert kingdom
terrorists try to behead mr cookie
president and record it all on a green
screen and a flag showing their logo of
two cookies the camera is made of graham
crackers and hard candy the tripod and
boom are candy canes the boom mic and
the gun tip are pastries one weapon is a
lollipop the thrown platform is a giant
sandwich cookie i get why rick would
want to come here because he's probably
hungry but it might also be because the
president and these beans are in the
form of simple rick's wafer cookies
which in the citadel rick's episode were
flavored with simple rick's sweet
memories one of the darker capitalist
metaphors that this finale actually
returns to morty is fixing rick's
forgotten messes and his list includes a
water city spider bot lava crystal tip
jar cookie freedom nuclear worm return
conch bean hordes and moon gremlin
return conch could refer to mr nimbus's
shell the source of his power stolen by
summer in the season premiere water city
could be this burst dam with a
ufo-shaped hole obviously created by
rick's car and then lava monster being
this monster with a stolen crystal which
sounds a lot like moana you can actually
see the slot on its head where that
crystal was supposed to be actually
later the crystal that turns jerry into
a puddle might have been the crystal
that would have extinguished this
monster like a kid refilling his parents
bottles of booze or what i and my
siblings did to accidentally ruin my
dad's scotch
morty tops off the depleted portal fluid
with soda recalling that dangerous
bootleg portal fluid in the tales from
the citadel episode bootleg portal fluid
i guess his math was off and notice how
now when morty pours it in it reads
weird fluid detected which is good
foreshadowing how evil president morty
has actually hacked all the rick's
portal guns to make it impossible for
them to leave the citadel morty when you
came here for that serum did you refill
this gun
yeah
oh
i only know one man that ever hacked my
portal gun and it turned out it was evil
you morty spills fluid on his palm
linking him with nick voiced by and
modeled on the likeness of rick and
morty rider nick rutherford to clean up
the trash rick summons a garbage goober
garbage goober get out here and eat this
garbage
trash yeah i love trash yum yum trash
and notice how later after eating it all
garbage goober looks spent rick spends
the wheel of better things than morty
which includes garbage goober jerry
spinning kyle 2.0 bag of meat sentient
two crows jean with donkey brain
and half of paul giamatti the whole
thing is on cardboard with scribbled
pupils even sloppier than the show's
character's typical eye design kyle 2.0
calls back rick's past assistant kyle
who was mentioned by mr nimbus in the
season premiere i liked your other one
more what was his name kyle what nothing
gene from nextdoor comes up again and
half of paul giamatti could be calling
back paul giamatti voicing the storylord
last season rick catches two crows with
a fake scarecrow version of himself
which might work because we later
learned these crows had a prior
relationship with crow scare nick tells
morty
break the cycle marty change the things
that you can change calling back rick's
cynical love advice to morty in season
one break the cycle morty rise above
focus on science meaning rick has just
been recycling the same advice to every
young person he meets though we actually
later learned that nick really followed
rick home after a night at the bar and
tried to steal his portal gun rick
trains the crows by having them ring a
bell to release food just like pavlov's
dog experiment where he had him ring a
bell that caused him to salivate
mordic's bike can convert into a
spaceship but i like how it still has
the pedals and dumb flag and front
basket like rick still wanted the
spaceship to look like a little kid's
bike nick is being held in high security
harteen psychiatric hospital and nod to
longtime rick and morty editor lee
hartin they escaped the hospital and
it's abusive guards who lick faces on
mondays and not a terminator 2 judgment
day when guards licks sarah connor's
face morty compares their slapstick
combat teamwork to jackie chan damn just
like jackie chan ha i guess that makes
me chris tucker but i guess referring to
jackie chan fighting with the broomstick
and jackie chan's first strike but
nick's only jackie chan reference point
is rush hour of course it is he sucks
rick and his crows seek a raiders of the
lost ark style golden idol in a temple
with a mallet that crushes the heads of
crying baby aliens what the hell after
the crows try to teach rick empathy he
rewards them by banishing them to an
avian planet which actually might be the
same planet as bird world homeworld of
bird person even one day of working
under me will make you apex geniuses
down there if bird person is there rick
might be saying that these crows are
smarter than his ex-friend just because
they spent a day with him still salty
morty says what if he catches us he
could trap me in a matrix again we later
learned rick has been farming mortys and
brainwashing them as mind slaves like
machines due to humans in the matrix
morty takes an early model portal gun
which has the same bulky shape as the
early model that scifi rig
offered in the season 3 premiere memory
which actually gets confirmed in the
finale here rick returns with the crows
and they were eating pancakes a reminder
of rick's favorite breakfast food that
he brought up in close rit counters i've
got pancakes back home with syrup on top
of them they're about to hit that
critical point of syrup absorption that
turns the cakes into a gross paste and i
hate to get all andy rooney about it but
i think we all like fluffy discs of cake
with syrup on top angry that rick
considered two crows on par with
sentient the elder crows unleash a
crow evolution which is essentially
alfred hitchcock's birds rick storms
their dark crystal meets hot topic ship
the elder crows actually do look a lot
like jim henson's puppets now rick later
uses a shield that looks like it is made
of those same harvested phoenix person
parts that he had sorted off to the side
in the previous episode suggesting to me
that rick's attachment to these two
crows might be rooted in his grief over
losing bird person's friendship
meanwhile morty flees nick when he
starts killing everyone i'm a portal boy
that name sucks i was just trying to yes
and yes and being the improv comedy term
to not judge whatever random thing your
seat partner says and just agree to it
and then build on it something that for
me looking back on 12 years dude improv
feels like the kind of thing that
enabled all the cult i went through
in those years morty escapes death by
amputating his own hand and then drops
his palm portal into nick's thigh
creating a kind of snake eating his own
tail paradox that sucks nick into
himself sucking myself into myself that
would be how i want to go after
cauterizing his stump on the jetpack
notice how morty first reaches down with
that stump arm to activate the jetpack
but then realizes he no longer has that
hand and has to activate it with the
other side rick uses a nice in handy
which scrolls through options of a hook
hand a clawed lizard hand a goofy
cartoony hand a hoof and then a spiky
hand from another alternate animated
style rick also offers to make it big
again like that one time recalling that
kind of stuff that led to morty's crisis
in episode four or when he got that big
john cena arm now with this episode's
title of forgetting sarah rick martial
as in for getting sarah marshall this is
of course a breakup episode and leads to
this really sad ending as morty cries
watching him go as rick resets his life
with the crows and then has a similar
rant of multiple seasons like did with
morty in the pilot episode and then a
post-credits scene revealing garbage
goober is a married doctor with a degree
from harvard medical school reading the
new england journal of medicine and that
brings us to episode 10 rick moray jack
a take on samurai jack which this first
part of the episode is clearly modeled
on down to its on-screen text of chapter
13 a wing and a prayer in a whole new
title sequence which if you listen
closely is set to the same melody of the
main rick and morty title music
little creepy detail here an owl grabs
this woman and uses its feather to
tickle her cheek
and when rick uses his swarm of crows to
fill the owl until he pops notice how
none of those crows come out afterward
meaning they all gave their lives to do
this after using phoenix person's tech
as a shield now he recreates phoenix
person's wings he really is transforming
himself into phoenix person by doing
this rick battles pucifer and morty
shows up having aged up to 40 years old
though still orders a rum and coke what
are you 20 here's your drink poser yeah
rum and coke is a drink that teenagers
think is what adults drink but uh we
don't need more sugary coke we need real
stuff that burns and hurts ruins our
lives the two girls sneak out to spend
their nights with crow scare and
throughout this apartment they got one
larger and two smaller suitcases already
packed we see the same with their
toothbrushes and hand towels for crow
scare crow and crow their past
adventures include trips to egypt to
mount rushmore los angeles norway wine
tasting so rick goes home and he takes
morty back to the citadel to d.h him now
this is the first time we have seen the
citadel since the evil president morty's
takeover which is why there's now a
morty dominant statue in the center and
notice way more mortys than rick's
walking around because the president has
been exterminating rix this whole time
they pass focto morty and a new mascot
hi i'm citadel's new mascot andy because
this place wouldn't be home without
ricks andy morty's dumb oh as they walk
off andy just stands there hurt i just
wanted to entertain 40 morty explains
there's a morty president now oh that's
cute they rebuilt they made it nicer
they made it glendale yeah some local
los angeles humor there glendale is part
of east l.a that has been kind of
commercialized with shopping centers
that are crowd friendly but a bit
soulless no offense if you live in
glendale your life is empty enough they
go to rebuild a morty like bill de bear
with spare morty parts stacked all over
the place there's the bearded morty from
the creepy morty bar entails from the
citadel also reptilian morty and then
they graphed out the center of forty
morty to make two seven year olds i like
crayons girls are gross and then merge
them into a 14 year old leaving a 26
year old morty left over i'm almost
ready to sell out all right what's
disposal cost now 26 year old morty has
the same arm tattoo that 40 year old
morty had suggesting that this was
something he would have gotten in his
20s that he is stuck with for anyone no
longer in her 20s the stuff you did then
doesn't leave you any cooler than you
are not quite the opposite you don't
want to remember anything from your 20s
but i'm not going to get sucked down
that theory rabbit hole no sir you know
what getting called sir or ma'am is fine
but you know what's better getting
called lord or lady well thanks to
established titles for sponsoring this
video these established titles is a
project based on a historic scottish
custom where landowners are referred to
as lards or lords and ladies in english
they let people buy as little as one
square foot of dedicated land so that
they can call themselves a lord or lady
and in return established titles commit
to planting a tree in scotland isn't
that cool it's a fun way to help
preserve the beautiful woodlands and
biodiversity of scotland while raising
funds to support global conservation
efforts plus for those with scottish
heritage it's a great way to connect to
your family roots so this is my
proclamation i am lord eric voss i get
to put this up in my home now and then
make my fiance call me lord and tease
her with the promise that she'll be a
lady one day i think that's how it works
your title packs give you a dedicated
land on a private estate in the ancient
medieval capital city of dunfermline
scotland with this official certificate
with a crest i can even visit my land in
scotland if i want to it really makes an
awesome gift for that friend or family
member who would really have a great
time with the whole lord or lady part of
it you can get a couple pack for you and
your partner and you can get adjoining
plots of land or if you're single
imagine what a lordship will do for your
dating profile so go to
establishtitles.com
new rockstars and get 10 off any orders
that's establishedtitles.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description a sewer morty gets
restrained by these security mortys who
all bear the new crest of evil morty
rick's r symbol replaced with a morty m
and they kill 26 year old morty was i
influential yeah you had like seven
seven blogs tight and then rick reminds
us that he did previously destroy the
citadel referring to the season three
premiere when he collided the federation
space station with it you know i
destroyed this place you've been
pardoned for that sir rick let's have
dinner with the morty president the idea
was to get back to simple adventures the
citadel runs on canon referring to how
episodes set in the citadel close rit
counters rickshank redemption tales from
the citadel these have been the episodes
that have moved forward the series
continuity in big ways as this episode
does and even rick with this meta
mindset anticipates that the president
morty is probably evil morty because how
else could any morty have that much
ambition but the second he reveals he's
evil we're gone president morty wears a
tie but rolled up sleeves going for that
folksy casual look that some real-life
politicians use to i guess look younger
or here to work but can you trust them
just put on a jacket i know you're cold
the president reveals that he was going
to hunt c-137 down and asks him it would
require less if you were willing to tell
me how one might bring down the central
finite curve ah the central finite curve
this term actually came up all the way
back in that season one episode of all
the ricks in the central finite curve
you're the malcontent and then later
came up again in the citadel of rick's
commercial for simple rix 60 iterations
off the central finite curve there's a
rick that works more with wood than
polarity plating
his name is simple rick president morty
brings up rick's memory scans rick
designing his car giving snuffles the iq
helmet memories that he got from that
first citadel episode when evil rick who
was a robot controlled by evil morty
stole them from his brains check out
season one episode nine rick heads excel
see her
so rick pops in as stan lee catchphrase
excelsior who would pop into marvel
comics to tell readers to refer to past
issues for context now if you look it up
season one episode nine might refer to
something wicked this way comes but only
when you include the pilot episode which
the rick and morty riders room doesn't
do because the pilot is usually written
and produced separately before the room
is assembled so for them 109 is close
rick counters of the red kind but the
memory scans end with rick's blueprints
for the citadel with a close-up of the
citadel's dimensional drive at the base
which is really the super laser
president morty's going to use as sewer
morty warned death is coming for us all
and the citadel is a weapon of masters
president morty mentions i was afraid
i'd have to kill every rick on the
citadel to get what i needed meaning
that the president did not plan on c-137
rick ever returning to the citadel
instead really what he was doing was
destroying the central finite curve by
scanning each and every rick in the
citadel for their home realities one at
a time explaining why no ricks are
around oh my god and the president
reveals to morty the truth putting him
in the eyes of one of those tortured
mortys on evil rick's dome from close
rick counters but this actually could be
evil morty's own eyes and he explains
how rix using morty's inverse brain
waves to hide was so efficient that
ricks began intervening with young beths
and young jerry's to make them fall in
love and when that wasn't enough cloning
mortys and farming them like livestock
there aren't infinite versions of our
grandfather morty he's an infinite smear
of one shitty old man and he's attached
to us infinitely through his weakness
and our forgiveness this is why we're
with him this is why we're alive now the
music matches the horns of don davis's
score in the matrix as this montage
definitely parallels morpheus's
description of machines farming humans
this also gives new context to rick's
cynicism about jerry and beth's
relationship i remember the first time i
saw her i thought i should get her
pregnant and then she'll have to marry
me i beg your pardon rick and to get out
of there rick uses his blood to spawn
this horny monster that is linked with
him to get off on the attacks in order
to give rick super strength which rick
calls a metaphor for capitalism so i
guess what he means by this is that this
creature represents the physical labor
of the masses that are deceived into
craving their exploitation that is
actually really for the benefit of the
uncaring capitalist yes the metaphor is
a bit strained i guess kind of like
slavery with extra steps a rick
broadcast tells everyone to stay which
of course is just gonna make everyone
want to leave leading to all of their
deaths one morty is wearing a medical
mask that one from the darkest timeline
for sure and gets burned to death
another gets ripped in half by
mechanical arms one goes through a meat
grinder a rick gets shot by a machine
gun and other by arrows there's one who
gets skewered by a giant olive toothpick
the citadel news host rick d716 dies
replaced by his co-host d716b both
returning from tales from the citadel
and morty plugs in rick's true backstory
finally confirming the season 3 premier
story as true younger rick refusing to
join that rick who first offered him
portal gun technology and beth and diane
dying in that bomb that was mysteriously
dropped from the portal we never know
who exactly did that if that was the
rebuffed rick it probably was i do go
into some alternate theories in our
episode to explain but now rick
depressed looks down at his pizza box
and then right from there invents his
portal gun and first settles in a pizza
dimension the one from that close rick
counters montage that was populated by
phone people who use humans as phones
which would according to logic make
pizza furniture as we see from the pizza
slice park bench rick builds a beta of
mind blowers helmet it looks like using
that blue crystal in order to print a
memory photo of the rick who he thinks
killed his family he ends up as a jaded
hunter wearing a trench coat eating
ramen with bird person all the imagery
and setting and the moody synth music
all very evocative of blade runner they
fight the federation we see the battle
of blood ridge memory when bird person
rejected his friendship as we saw in
episode 8 then rick finds a reality
where rick is in a different garage and
a smith fairly with summer and a female
morty and then follows that rick's star
map to this rick outpost and i guess
it's a clubhouse seems like the origins
of rick's idea for the citadel there's a
banner on the wall with the r logo that
is later uses the citadel's logo and
then the three stars of that logo being
the three stars of this constellation
that he followed to get there there are
photos of known alternate ricks strung
together on the wall including the
turkey rick from the season's
thanksgiving episode a hellboy rick
there's rick sombrero get up from the
unity episode looks like rick with
klingon forehead ridges then jack rick
from the something rickett episode and
then the helmeted aqua rick c137 kills
off rix one by one following one to the
heart of a maze but fails losing himself
in alcohol and killing every rick who
comes for him and then yeah we see why
the council of ricks assumed c137 was
the rick murdering all the other ricks
in that first citadel episode but rick
forms the council of ricks and the
citadel and returns to beth who is alive
in this reality though it's never
explained whether her mom in that
reality is also alive or how her mom
would have died and then we zoom out all
of this is contained in one universal
sphere of the central finite curve
alongside other realities of a tiger
rick and tiger morty as well as shrimp
rick from the season 4 premiere and then
other animal variations but those
peaceful realities are just in rick's
perspective because when evil morty
shows them the curve shows morty's in
pain and rick as bloody butchers eva
morty explains how rick created this
multiverse curve using only realities
where he is the alpha genius so every
time a green portal is opened it's only
the reality where rick is the smartest
person in that universe and as this is
explained we glide past moments where
rick was at his lowest his suicide
attempt at the end of the unity episode
his self owning on the toilet seat in
season 4 episode 2 morty's saving him in
the season 5 premiere and rick not
knowing which beth was the clone in the
season 4 finale even morning explains
he's not evil he's just sick of rick and
that all morty's eventually become him
and he uses a portal fluid to beam a
rift in reality separate from the
central finite curve a rick and morty
pair with orange froze try to engage
operation phoenix to let themselves die
and respawn which is a contingency we've
seen rick use on the series before but
evil morty counted on them doing that
and he uses their blood to identify the
remaining universes on a central finite
curve and erasing them so they escape to
the mortyberg region of the citadel as
evil morty plunges himself into that
rift in reality while the evil morty
theme music plays and he blasts through
it much like the stargate sequence in
2001 at space odyssey i would say the
black hole tesseract sequence of
interstellar though dan harmon's not a
big fan of that meanwhile our rick and
morty are left marooned with no portal
fluid left in their gun and evil morty
crosses the event horizon and opens a
new yellow portal meaning this is
reality where rick is not the alpha
genius of it but more likely a reality
where this morty now is leaving us
wondering is this series now gonna be
called morty and rick as this morty
pairs with an average empathetic sweet
natured rick and what of that murderous
sci-fi rick who got away after killing
diane and beth since he was never found
could this guy have followed through on
his ambitions to create his own
community multiverse of ricks his own
central finite curve questions to
consider as we move on to the
post-credits scene that brings back mr
poopybutthole similar to the
post-credits scenes after the season 2
finale and after the season 3 finale
when we saw he had a loving family but
now that family is gone and he lives
alone in a crummy studio apartment
pictures of his family still up but he
eats instant ramen right out of the pot
he leaves all the rappers on the floor
wish i was brave enough to love them
back i don't know maybe you should try
it we don't have as much time as we
think ooh
this was writer jeff loveness's final
episode before moving on to writing
marvel movies and he tweeted his script
for this scene advising all of us to
learn from him you can support new
rockstars by checking out our great
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thank you for watching thanks
for joining me this season of rick and
morty it's been a lot of fun bye
[Music]
you